welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Bradley Woodworth he is the
coordinator of Baltic Studies at Yale
University and assistant professor of
history at the University of New Haven
his research interests include the
social and political history of the
multi-ethnic baltic provinces and the
broader northwestern regions of Imperial
Russia including st. Petersburg and
Finland today we'll talk with Professor
Woodworth about the most recent volume
he co-edited with Carsten Brueggemann of
Tallinn University entitled Russia on
the Baltic Imperial strategies of power
and cultural patterns of perception 16th
to 20th centuries
welcome professor Woodworth thank you
for inviting me let's begin with you
giving us an overview of the book tell
us about it
right so this book is a collaborative
effort 17 scholars are involved and
these are scholars that have been
writing over the last few years about
the historical relationship between the
Baltic region this is understood in our
scholarship here as the territories that
today comprise these states of Estonia
Latvia and Lithuania the scholars are
writing about this region with regard to
its relationship with the Russian Empire
as well as the Soviet Union in new ways
that breaks with scholarship that had
dominated in the 20th century for four
decades the scholarship they story
ography about this region focused on
Imperial domination from the capitals of
st. Petersburg in the Imperial period
and in Moscow in the Soviet period with
the Baltic region and its peoples being
more or less passive recipients of this
domination and violence now with my
co-editor we had never downplay in any
way this history of violence
particularly in the 20th century but we
feel that now with 20 years after the
fall of the Soviet Union it's time to
reassess the broader and deeper
historical relationship between the
Imperial center
and this particular borderland of what
was a very multi-ethnic Russian Empire
and Soviet Union and look at it in new
ways and see what areas of the
historical relationship have been maybe
misunderstood or or downplayed because
of this Rainie paradigm of violence and
domination now how did you go about did
you invite these people to provide you
with paper did it grow out of something
else or how did write actually well so
between the two of us we have a lot of
contacts among scholars working on the
Baltic region as well as the
multi-ethnic Russian Empire we attended
conferences in Europe on Baltic affairs
in Baltic history as well as in North
America and from several conference we
saw some commonalities and approach
among these scholars and so we
approached them about this idea and
found a publisher in Berlin the project
took a little bit longer than I think we
had anticipated but we're very pleased
with the result okay let's talk about
some of the perceptions or insights that
the book brings to light right so the
main one as I mentioned before is that
the relationship between an imperial
center and it's it's it's peripheries
the Russian Empire had a number of
peripheral regions on its border lands
in the North on the west and on the
south and then later in the 19th century
acquiring central central asia its
history with siberia also historically a
non Russian region goes back a number of
centuries the historical experience with
these non Russian areas was central to
the identity of the Russian Empire with
the region that we're studying we've
were determined that in the last couple
hundred years we the relationship though
has in the historiography had been
dominated by this discourse of violence
and domination there are a lot of other
things that were going on so we're
hoping to reopen these questions of the
relationship between between center and
periphery now when you were
editing the papers did you come across
anything that was particularly
surprising to you anything you weren't
expecting yeah I think one thing that
was a little bit unexpected is how long
it took to produce the book how long did
it take well it took about five years
actually they're some of the papers were
originally delivered in 2007 and 2000
2008 I believe and so we approached the
authors and started working on them and
I found that the process of putting
together a multilingual volume with a
with a publisher outside of the United
States and authors who whose native
language ranges across the board we had
authors from six different countries and
I think I guess five different languages
I really was a time consuming after
because we wanted to make sure that the
final product reflected the quality of
the research of those scholars so we
spent quite a bit of time working on on
those chapters and editing them and
working and going back and forth that
the authors among the 17 chapters nine
are in English those are the ones that I
edited and professor Brueggemann edited
the eight chapters in German and among
the nine chapters that I worked on
including the introduction that
Professor brew come on Mike crow
together in English there was only one
other chapter that was written by a
native English speaker and so there was
a spend of quite a bit of work you know
in those chapters quite a melting pot
and quite I think a variety of
perspectives then as a result of people
coming from different countries yeah so
this is one thing that both Tressa
Brueggemann and I have noticed
interestingly neither of us have our own
in sense personal historical ties to the
region okay this is a part of the of the
world that requires a lot of languages
to understand and so it's understandable
that often scholars that are interested
in the region have some sort of personal
contact maybe within their family but
professor Bruggeman is originally from
Germany I have no family ties to the
Baltic region but for a number of number
of reasons found myself having spent
over four years in in the former Soviet
Union in three years in Estonia so we've
we found that there were an increasing
number of scholars like us that were
I think probably coming to the region
with a new set of eyes over the last few
decades during the existence of the
Soviet Union
the kinds of historical writings from
the Baltic region
I wouldn't say were completely dominated
by this by this discourse of violence
and and an imperial ambitions from the
center you know to rule and to let
everyone know that they were subject
peoples but it's understandable but
that's sort of that sort of disc in this
course exists I mean the history of the
Baltic region beginning in 1940 when it
was first occupied by the Soviet Union
all the way up to 1991 was one of
Ireland's in 1941 in the summer tens of
thousands of people from each of the
three countries that had been
independent between World War one and
World War two you're speaking of Latvia
Lithuania Estonia were exiled to Siberia
and many of those people never of course
ever returned many people left those
countries as political refugees fleeing
Soviet occupation so even after the war
ended the violence then continued when
the Soviet Union reoccupied the country
and again deported people to Siberia
over the next few decades there were
tens of hundreds of thousands of people
brought from outside the Baltic region
but from other other other areas of the
Soviet Union to work in new building new
growing factories and so the demographic
picture of these countries changed
dramatically so far that in in Latvia in
particular by the late 1980s the
percentage of the population living in
the country that was ethnically Latvia
was approaching 50% which means that in
the country that is you know the the
homeland of a people they could [ __ ]
they could have found themselves
minorities and the demographic picture
was also quite quite dire in Estonia so
the the under the the problematic
relationship with with the Eastern power
of Russia and the Soviet Union
professor Birmingham I completely
understand
but the fact is that from the 18th
century and even earlier this was a
multi-ethnic region
people have differing ethnicities
differing religions differing languages
lived together no one in the 18th
century or 19th century knew that there
was going to be this thing called modern
nationalism that people would divide
themselves according to in some ways a
somewhat artificial category of
nationalism because nation can fall
along a number of different lines
dividing one people one nation from and
from another or that the Soviet they the
bigge Russian Empire would even collapse
in World War one nobody foresaw that so
people live together for 200 years they
were they worked on problems together
yes there were there were patterns of
people dominating when there was a local
elite in the Baltic region these were
people for the most part who had
historical ties to Germany well rather -
they were Germans I should say Germany
itself doesn't become a unified state
into the 19th century but one of these
minorities in the Baltic region that is
today Latvia and Estonia were Baltic
Germans and these people had had
long-standing ties in the country many
of them had arrived in the Middle Ages
so they'd have been there a long long
time and they had developed historical
ways of dealing with local populations
and during the 19th century in
particular and in the 20th century those
historical relations started to be
overturned by the Soviet Union okay so
if there was one thing that you'd like
your reader to take away what would it
be yeah a number of things I think I
think the the main thing that that
invigorates but my scholarship as well
as a professor bromans is this reality
of multi-ethnic societies what makes
them run how what makes them work how
when do they work successfully what kind
of problems do they have and give you
one example from Karsten brooder monza
essay he writes about how in the 19th
century when Russia was beginning to
have a stronger whole than the Baltic
region
stronger presence the Russians who were
writing about the region and this
included historians included publicists
and another another writers were very
much attracted to the region this was a
region that had a higher level of
culture a higher level of literacy than
Russia proper and they realized the
strong role of cultural culture bringing
school - Latoya that the Germans had
been but on the other hand they were
trying to reimagine this this
multi-ethnic area is something that
belonged to a multi-ethnic Russian
Empire which itself sought which saw
itself as having a civilizing mission a
mission see of these CBDs entities and
so there was a very interesting process
of give-and-take really between local
populations in the center in coming up
with a with a new identity for this
region within the Russian Empire another
article by you getting us out of them an
interesting great scholar from Russia
writes about how Latvians in the 19th
century who became educated to the point
that they didn't always find a place for
them to work in the baltic provinces
often left to russia and had careers
there in a postal service and the
military across the board another
scholar from from Estonia in the in the
collection writes about how in the 19th
century there were transyl transfers
from the Baltic to Russia again with
many areas of scholar scholarship and
science being at higher levels in the
Baltic than in Russia there were things
that the Baltic could actually offer
Russia and one that she writes about our
cultural transfers in the area of
Agriculture to where Baltic Germans were
able to show colleagues in Russia how to
make better use of the land so this is
the thing that is always really
interested interested us about this
multi-ethnic region and another couple
other things I say come out of the of
the book and that is that multi-ethnic
regions really can't be seen or
shouldn't be seen rather as a land where
on there's on the one hand
imperial power that dominates over local
supine populations these are these are
shared regions it doesn't mean that
everybody's living happily at the same
time but they really need to be looked
at as a whole
and not just in terms of in this case
for example Russia on the one hand and
Baltic on the other Russian interests
versus Baltic interests we really see
them as together this is a shared
territory and we're trying to understand
it on those shared terms and then
finally what emerges from the region so
both of us have a deep commitment to the
Baltic region and that's all that comes
clear I think comes out in the book but
we're also trained as Russian historians
and this book I think plays a part in
the really the dominant three theme
right now is studying the the Russian
Empire and that is the issue of its
multi ethnicity it never got the the the
time it deserved and passed in past
decades particularly while the Soviet
Union existed but with the collapse of
the Soviet Union there's been a new boom
and scholarship about about these non
Russian areas and so our book I think
helps help scholars in approaching this
question what was this thing called
Imperial Russia no was it a was it a
nation-state in embryo was it multiple
in the nation-states in embryo was it
imperial center with with autonomous
regions was it a multi-ethnic Empire
well it was all of these it was various
historical actors had their own visions
of what it was and I think we really
have to go back and look at what these
historical actors saw themselves as
doing what did they see themselves as
trying to create in this multi-ethnic
Empire and we hope our book is a
contribution to understanding that
fascinating do you have any other
projects lined up well thank you yes I'm
completing a book on Tollan in the
second half of the nineteenth century
and it looks at some of the similar
issues this was a multi-ethnic city and
one with where social change growing
national identity we're all taking place
at the same time and
I take a somewhat optimistic view of the
19th century and seen it one is great of
great possibilities and so I hopefully
finished that fairly soon and I'm also
working on an interesting fellow who
probably is the most famous Finn of all
time his name is Gustav Monahan who
himself was not a so called ethnic thin
but actually a Finnish Swede Swedish was
was his native language and he was born
in what was the Russian Empire Finland
was part of the Russian Empire in the
19th century and wanted to become a
military man and he did and he became a
eventually a general in the Czar's army
mm-hmm well he had an entire career
before World War one took place but with
World War one the collapse of Imperial
Russia Finland found itself vying for
independence and the end and he ended up
entering a whole new career of his life
which II think carries forward later in
his in his later years he end up as the
head of the Finnish forces in world war
two but he's another he's one of these
figures whose life isn't bounded right
by it by either of these stories and an
imperial center or or over a local Nash
a local a local Nation one one
particular identity it was it was a his
own his own life was a multi-ethnic one
and the richness of that experience and
I think the ways that it can comunit
communicate to societies today shouldn't
be lost very good thank you so much for
being here with us today and sharing
some of your work well thank you for the
invitation
I enjoyed it thank you for more
information about Professor Woodworth
and his research please visit our
website at Yale udu slash McMillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the McMillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty McMillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you